everything can change in an instant
whether or not you're ready this wasn't
the world I wanted but it was the one I
found myself in this time I'm ready
because I know
war war never changes
I have a question the only question that
matters would you risk your life for
your fellow man even if that man is a
synth
beneath the common world there is a kids
known as the Institute a malignant
growth that needs to be cut before it
infects the surface they're the real
enemy not the Raiders not the super
mutants
even those tools over died
I swear I'm not a sin for God's sakes
for family this is ridiculous
I want to truce with Donna
protect the people at a minutes notice
and decide our own future
a man out of time but also novelist
this campaign will be costly but in the
end we will be saving humankind from its
worst enemy itself
so where is it this Institute how do I
get there
haven't you been paying attention you
don't find the Institute
the Institute finds you
let's go boy